Okay.
Alhamdulillah.
[Silence]
continuing in
the fifth chapter, the chapter of
vigilance of Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala's
observation authored by
yesterday we spoke about the seventh
narration,
the narration
of
in which the prophet sallall.aii
was narrated to have said,
"The intelligent
and the
prudent is the one
who holds himself to account and works
for that which is after death."
and and makes the bulk of his efforts
for that which is after death.
And the loser is the one
who allows himself everything
his self desires
and then audaciously wishes that Allah
would do for him. This narration was
collected by
who graded it acceptable. Now we
spoke before
about this narration and the meaning
of it being correct and being a
statement of wisdom. No doubt. However,
that it has weakness in its chain of
narrators, its chain of transmission,
particularly a man by the name of Abu
Bakr Abi Muriam
who was a scholar of hadith and
renowned and known for his
truthfulness.
however not known for his accuracy
and this is this is a point here when we
look at a a narrator and the reason I'm
mentioning this narration again today is
because yesterday after the after we
concluded I was asked a a rather good
question which I think mystifies a lot
of people and that is if a narration is
considered weak. It's a weak in
irerration
and we do not believe that it's the
prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam's
words per se. We can't affirm it or
ascribe it to him with any kind of
certainty. Then where do weak narrations
come from? Right? That's a good nar
that's a good question.
You know there are three
general buckets or three general
categories. Let's say number one that
which is authentic. We we consider this
to be Allah's or we consider this to be
the prophet sallall alaihi wasallam's
words. The second category is that which
is inauthentic
and that is what we don't consider to be
the prophet's words even though they are
ascribed to him. And the third are
fabrications.
All right? Those things which were
intentionally
fabricated,
made up and then ascribed to the prophet
sallall.aii wasallam.
So we have one category that we're sure
of
are his words. Another category that we
are sure of are not his words.
Those are fabrications.
And then we have between those two
extremes
we have the no man's land of narrations
which do not reach the level of
authenticity for us to be able with any
kind of certainty to say
because that's a very big statement
isn't it? imagine the responsibility
in making such an audacious statement
as
the messenger of Allah said that is a
huge statement that's quite a mouthful
there are few other statements that
carry such
weight and there are few other claims
that carry such significance. Why is
that? When we look at humanity,
we see people who are influential.
But all of those influential people,
scholars, you know, throughout
history,
these people, no matter what they say,
their words in themselves are not an
evidence.
Their words thems are not innately
an evidence.
They need to have evidence in old in
order to bolster their words to be able
to say that's correct because
except for the prophets and messengers.
The prophets and messengers their words
are innately
evidence.
Those words themselves are to be taken
as evidence
that those words of the prophets and
messengers are not to be taken and
weighed
for you know to be correct. They are
self-evidently correct and they are an
evidence. They are the words by which
all other words are judged.
So the words of our prophet Sam
are extremely weighty very grave because
Allah says
whoever obeys the messenger has obeyed
Allah and the opposite meaning what's
insinuated is and whoever disobys the
messenger has disobeyed Allah. as a big
thing. For this reason, the criteria
that the scholars of Islam hold
and the criteria that they have set up
in order for a narration to be accepted
as being the words of the prophet
sallall.aii wasallam is extremely
high criteria,
very difficult. Only the best of the
best with respect to narrators are going
to be relied upon
when we discuss authenticity.
So
when we say a narration is authentic,
we are saying with reasonable
certainty.
What does that mean with reasonable
certainty? without a reasonable
doubt.
These are the words, these are the
actions of the prophet sallall.aii
wasallam in this particular narration.
When we have a weak narration,
what that means is we are unable to
obtain that level of certainty.
Is it possible
that a weak narration
may have actually been the words of the
prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam but
because of this weak narrator
it is then not considered part of the
authentic. It's possible. It's possible.
However, in order for us to be able to
rely on a narration,
we have to be able to reach that level
of
reasonable certainty. Notice the words
that I'm using, reasonable certainty.
Right?
And if a narration is inauthentic, this
means that its chain of narration cannot
bolster it to reasonable certainty.
There is a reasonable doubt there.
Right? Because the sunnah of the prophet
sallall.aii wasallam was not narrated by
one or two men. Not one or 2,000 men.
Tens of thousands of people made it into
the books of hadith. And from those tens
of thousands of people,
hundreds of thousands of people did not
make it into the books of hadith. That
is how
many people are involved in
transmitting the prophet sallall.aii's
sunnah. And when we say people, we're
not speaking about Joe Schmo, the guy at
the grocery store. Oh yeah, I was
around. I heard him once say this. Or,
oh yeah, you know, I heard a companion
once say such and such, some nobody.
We're speaking about the best of the
best of scholars. Someone that we are
able to trace him from the moment he
began studying until the day that he
died, where he went, who he met with,
who his Mashiah are, who his students
are, who his peers were. And that's even
more important because imagine this
gathering here. We've got about what, 20
of us in here now. Imagine I say
something, I make a statement, right?
And then we all leave and then
you know a couple months from now
brother says yes I was in such and
such gathering and I heard she Ali say
one two three but everybody else that
was there didn't hear that.
Now we know what happened if
is considered a trustworthy narrator. He
made a mistake or it's likely he made a
mistake or if he is an untrustworthy
narrator, it means that he's playing
some kind of games. Right? This is how
the chains of narration work. It's not
just one guy. Yes. When I compile a book
Al Bkari compiled a book and then
he mentions a narration he says one
person narrates that this person
narrates that this person narrates
that's only the chain of narration that
he chose for that book doesn't mean it's
the only chain of narration. That
particular narration may have sometimes
up to hundreds of chains of narration
with the same exact statement. Hundreds.
Because if you imagine a major companion
goes to
some,
you know, some town or some city, all
the scholars of that town are going to
descend upon this companion. And when he
speaks, they're all writing. They're all
listening. And then when they become
very prominent after that companion has
passed away, he goes to a town, all the
scholars of that town will descend upon
him and so forth. So we have
dozens sometimes hundreds of people
at every generation narrating that same
narration.
But then when we have a narration
which is only narrated by one person and
this one person is known to make
mistakes
and his peers did not narrate that
narration. He's the only one right even
though his peers who are more
knowledgeable about that particular
she's narrations
didn't mention that narration now we put
it in the pile of what's uncertain.
That's what's called weak. It's called a
weak narration.
Now
going back to that original notion that
we mentioned and that is that a
narration
could be the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam's words but then a weak
narrator happens to make his way into
the chain of narration and so the
narration is graded weak because of him.
Does that mean that we've lost a part of
the sunnah?
No. Why? Because
the prophet sallallah.aii wasallam
sunnah is
repeated. The nature of it is that is
repetitive.
Right? This statement here, let's look
at focus back on this statement.
The intelligent, the prudent, the wise
is a man who brings himself to account
and
places the bulk of his efforts
in that which will be consequential
after death. this statement in these
exact words. If we were to say this is a
weak narration,
are there other narrations
that hold this same exact meaning? Huh?
There are probably dozens, maybe even
hundreds of other narrations that hold
the exact same meaning, just in
different words.
How about the Quran? Does the Quran
contain this exact meaning, these same
meanings? If you were to read the Quran,
would you not come to this exact
conclusion? That the intelligent is the
one who brings himself to account and
works for that which is after death and
that the loser is the one who That's the
moral of the story. That's what you
learned from the Quran. That's what you
gathered from it. Yeah, of course,
that's exactly what you would the
conclusion you would come to.
Therefore, was any part of the Sunnah
lost? No. There's no such thing as a
critical part of the Sunnah being so
weakly narrated that it is subject to
loss along the way. Right? If something
is very important, it's going to be said
over and over and over. And there won't
just be one verse or two verse, many
verses and many narrations, right? And
that is just speaking about the Quran
and Sunnah. Then we go into the realm of
what the companions said. And that's a a
whole other level of narration and
things that the companions learned from
the prophet sallall.aii wasallam. And
that is why it is a bigger issue than
just one narration or two narrations.
When a narration is graded authentic, it
has to fit a larger scheme of themes. It
can't just come out of left field. It
has to fit a hand in a glove with
the rest of the Quran and the rest of
the Sunnah. Who tells us that this fits
or doesn't fit?
Who is it that tells us this? Is it the
guy on Facebook or the guy on YouTube or
Joe Schmo or Tom Dick and Harry? Or is
it's the scholars of Islam and not just
any scholars. We're talking about the
upper
1% of scholars in our generation that
will make these statements. And not only
that, but even if a scholar who is the
most major scholar of our time in all
the world, if he were to make a
statement,
he can't just make that statement out of
thin air. It has to trace itself back
what? 1,500
years worth of other scholars going back
to the prophet sallall.aii wasallam.
His words have to fit into that.
because there's no such thing as the
Muslim discover something new about
their religion that no one ever knew
1500 years before. That's not how this
works. If you make a statement, an
opinion, right? This is an opinion of a
scholar. It has to be bolstered by other
opinions. You can't just come up with it
out of thin air. So, it is a it is a
full ecosystem. You you you know when
they speak about like
how biologists for instance
speak about
species and their effects on the
ecosystem, right? for instance the
mosquito if if the mosquito disappeared
tomorrow,
what impact would that have? Oh, well,
the creatures that eat those that rely
on those mosquitoes would then die and
then the predators that rely on those
would then die and then it would reach
all the way and impact human beings. It
would impact the air. It would impact
the ozone layer. It would impact, you
know, whatever it is that they say. This
is exactly how the Quran and Sunnah
work.
It is an entire ecosystem
that if one part were to be removed, it
will affect it all the way over here in
a kind of butterfly effect. And that's
why the prophets that's why Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala said
he says do they not and contemplate the
Quran and come to the conclusion that if
it was from other than Allah they would
find much they would find much
contradiction in it because a human
being innately contradicts himself. It's
it's human nature and it is only Allah
subhanahu wa'ta'ala who is able to go
[Arabic recitation]